[Music]
hello to all the viewers we are back
with another episode of what's up Rafa
this is a special episode we are going
to continue discussing the coronavirus
because it's such a relevant topic at
this stage and without wasting any time
hello Walter
I will you peace open for us with a word
of Prayer
absolutely Heavenly Father there are
momentous events taking place in the
world and we need heavenly wisdom to
unravel them so I pray for your spirit
and your guidance in Jesus name Amen the
developments around the coronavirus has
escalated through many ously in the last
few days the world we woke up to last
week is not the world we woke up to this
mortal can you tell us some information
that you've received what's going on in
the what's going on in the world well
let me let me start off right from the
beginning of the bat that there are so
many stories about the coronavirus on
the internet for example there were a
number of prophecies and people are all
hyped up about the prophecies Sylvia
brown predicted that in the year 2020
there would be this virus and it would
stay for a short time and go away there
were books written prior to that and
explaining that these things would come
there were TED talks by gates for
example that this was something that was
on the horizon not just a possibility
but a probability there were movies that
were made about these things contagion
and
the movies so it seems as if the mind of
humanity has been put into a groove to
accept the inevitability of such an
event now let me say right from the
beginning this is not a program where we
are going to discuss any one of these
theories or get into conspiracy theories
around about this issue and we're not
going to discuss whether all of these
things are legitimate or not legitimate
when we are we have to err on the side
of caution
that means we accept that the
information that we have is genuine to
an extent and we even go along with any
legislations that are in the pipeline
and we try to be responsible citizens so
that is off the bat and of course if
legislation should be enacted which is
contrary to God's law then that becomes
a different story so today I don't
really want to talk about the legitimacy
necessarily we'll mention one or two
things and about the the fact that you
know this is a crisis I want to talk
more about what is the outcome wizard
actually heading this and what is the
possible or probable outcome and we need
some some sound information regarding
this now there have been a number of
developments and escalations for example
the German government announced major
escalations
in terms of restrictions on humanity and
freedom of association and all of these
issues and there was a very interesting
discussion on television in Germany I
think it was yesterday and it's
brand-new if I can just give some
information it was by the Institute for
science research and community politics
in German that would be Institute for
Vision shafts for Chaumont gazelle
shafts politic and a expert in the field
of Epidemiology and an expert in
respiratory diseases dr. Wolfgang
verdict was the spokesman and I found it
fascinating we can't play it for the
viewers because it's in German but I
found it fascinating that he was totally
surprised at the way in which this thing
was being handled because he said that
the virus the corona virus forms a part
of the general flu population of viruses
and even if the percentage amidst all
the other flu viruses is up to 15% then
never in the past when they were veralyn
tyrus --is around was one virus isolated
from the rest of the group and made the
object of so much attention yes correct
and he mentioned for example the swine
flu which is a very serious flu and
affected numerous people never in the
past was this removed from the package
of viruses and made a special subject
for pandemics the same with the bird flu
the HN viruses and they also weren't
isolated and when there was testing done
then it wasn't isolated from the
made the subject for special rules and
regulations and he says the same should
apply for this and he doesn't understand
why there is such a hype and who
benefits from the hype and this is an
interesting point that he raised he gave
various statistics and outcomes and it
was a very interesting discussion
nevertheless there was a document that
was released by the German government in
other words an official document and
that document was called let me just get
my information here it came from the
Deutsche Bundesbank in other words it's
a official document and it's talks AAHA
zips in that means press release 17 / 1
2 0 5 1 and it was released in 2013 and
based on research in this field around
possible epidemics and catastrophes and
how the state should respond to those
and I found this document so fascinating
because it comes from 2012 yes so you
know that's 8 years ago that's quite a
long time ago and the first part of the
document deals with flooding and what
the governmental response should be
should there be a large amount of
flooding and then the second half of the
document deals with risk analysis and
protecting the population against the
pandemic by a virus such as Modi sauce
and I have the document before me and I
find it fascinating because it is like a
blueprint of what we are seeing
the world today in fact it mirrors its
so exactly it's like a script it's like
a script and I find that incredibly
interesting and if I can go back to the
movies that were made these movies are
of course also possible scripts of
possible outcomes of events and I've
always in my previous lectures spoken
about the The Hollywood world as nothing
other than Jesuit theater so are we
following a script is the possibility
again let me reiterate this is not about
whether this is real or whether it is
not real we're talking about the
possible outcomes in terms of the
prophetic ramifications of such an
outbreak so when I go through this
document this remember 2012 that's a
long time ago yes and apparently that is
about the time when the coronavirus made
its first appearance even in Germany and
was then labeled as a possible vehicle
for this kind of pandemic so the
document gives a analysis of how this
thing will pan out and it says what is
the probability of this thing happening
and I say highly probable so this is
going to happen yes so it's it's a it's
a blueprint for how to react when it
does happen they have a table right in
the beginning where they look at the
ramifications and the damage that will
be caused by such an outbreak and they
later on in the document give you the
numbers that are involved now Angela
Merkel just recently had
a public announcing where she had very
grave appearance and said that 70% of
the people will probably be affected by
this virus yes
now the start of Afghan voter also was
asked the same question what about what
about the the ramification that so many
people should be infected and he said
you know what if you go into a epidemic
or just a normal flu scenario then
people get the flu yeah and over a
period of time it can be up to 70% of
the population that has the flu if you
ask someone did you get a flu posture
then most of the people will say yes and
some people will say no I escaped the
flu this year
yes but most will say they had it at
least once so if a couple escaped then a
70% getting the flu is nothing out of
the ordinary but if there is no direct
proof as to which virus caused that flu
then it gets dumped into this big basket
which is called flu and if you have
enough of this hype then everybody has
now got the so virus it's interesting to
me that in America there was this
article where doctor mark Segal said
well this is this is very strange
because they have all of these people
but number one they're not supposed to
see them because they are infectious so
you must basically have an interview
with them over the phone to see whatever
it is and then the test kids aren't
generally available as to which specific
virus you are testing for and so most of
these people are not really tested the
test kits are not available and so you
don't actually see them
they are at home and you do not test
them but and they laugh the symptoms but
you don't know are they're just normal
symptoms that are associated with a
normal flu or not even the labs are not
gonna taste the taste Steve they sent it
exactly because there could be a risk of
them being infected so this is this is
rather strange so if you go back to this
this graphic representation of what the
effect will be it is divided into
categories of what is the effect on the
human being what is the effect on the
environment what is the effect on the
economy and what is the other other
effects and we'll talk about some of
them now deaths they're talking here
about categories from A to E and the
maximum there in E is supposed to be run
about seven and a half million deaths as
a consequence so the impact they say on
humanity is going to be very high with
million seven and a half million
probable deaths
injured or people that are sick in the
same number of catching in the same
category and those that need help again
maximum so we're talking in the millions
and then a very interesting category
those that went missing yeah and that is
a relatively high number so if we
consider that the maximum here is seven
and a half million then the number of
missing people here could be between a
third and half of that yes so that's
quite a number of people just gone
missing and I explained it by saying
well maybe they were on a trip and
didn't come back or whatever they're
just gone and then as to the impact on
the environment
any damage to the environment or certain
areas of the environment or buildings or
ground waters or useful surfaces zero
damage then some of the animal kingdom
especially those that are in the
agricultural sector there might be
minimal damage as far as they are
concerned so the damage lies with human
beings and then the next one is a very
interesting category with maximum damage
and that is the economy the people's
economy in other words the men on the
street not necessarily the big companies
but the general economy it is to have a
major major impact and then also impact
on the public order will be very high
that means you can expect disobedience
of obedience you can expect riots you
can expect all of these things and the
political ramifications will be massive
and the psychological ramifications will
be massive and then cultural heritage
sites they won't be affected at all so
it seems as if the economy especially
the people's economy humanity in general
and the political ramifications will be
maximum but now what fascinates me about
this document is the detail because it's
quite a long document the whole document
is well over 80 pages and this is
probably two-thirds of the document
dealing with this and I think to deal
with the whole document just highlight a
few points number one this pandemic will
be worldwide it will be a worldwide
pandemic
because you cannot contain a virus
obviously and what will be the probable
vector what will be the one that will
cause the problem so the scenario is
that the heavier is a hypothetical Modi
SARS virus and then they say for example
SARS coronavirus Co V well that's
interesting that is now eight years ago
so the probable virus could be the
corona virus or then they throw in there
the h5n1 influenza virus or even some
other and like HIV or something but the
first one they mentioned is such corona
virus covary and and this virus was
first isolated around about 2012 in six
patients now it's interesting that if
you take that same number today that's
also where it would have started yes but
there was no pandemic at that stage
regarding this virus now let's describe
what happens they're saying in this org
in this article they're talking about
the incubation time of the virus and how
long it will take before you develop
symptoms that would be five days then 14
days before it manifests itself strongly
and what it does it detects respiratory
system and you can become dizzy and you
can get cramps and be and the lethality
and nowlet allottee is an interesting
term it's those that will die as a
consequence of the infection in other
words not of the whole population but of
those that infect it will be high so
what does that really mean and then
where will it appear that's interesting
they say it will appear or be manifested
particularly in Asia North America
and Europe yes now that's interesting
why not in the rest well one of the
reasons why they could actually say that
probably is because of the next data
which they will say so initially it will
only be ten cases in Germany and then it
will spread out until virtually 70
percent of the population as Angela
Merkel said would get this now when will
this happen exactly and they say this
will occur in February in Asia now isn't
it interesting that this virus broke out
in Asia in February now this is eight
years ago that they're saying that it'll
probably come from Asia and then a
couple of weeks later its dimensions
will be realized and then in April it
will be identified as motifs are
coronavirus and then it will come to
Europe and the United States so it comes
out of South East Asia which is China
and it'll come from the the market place
where the animals are and that's exactly
what happened now I find this rather
fascinating that it is following this
plan and then only to people who had
been in Asia will bring the disease to
Europe and from there it will spread
rapidly now what is interesting to me is
the duration this is very fascinating
because there's a lot of different oh
yeah
opinions about I mean it was said that
it will last only a few weeks and then
it was a few months
let's just see what they say and then
we'll get back to what some people are
saying ground so how long will this
development continue and we can we can
have new cases appearing all the time
but it seems as if the duration will
probably be three years so this document
says three years so when we get back to
what the media is saying today they said
a few weeks yeah and they said three
months then I think Donald Trump said
six months and now the latest already is
an announcement in Germany that the
restrictions as a consequence of the
virus at this stage is estimated to be
about two years so we're getting really
close to the three years and then they
have a graph here as to how it pans on
and you will see on the graph that on
the one hand they have the number of
people that get sick in percentage and
at the bottom they have a three year
period in days so there's 360 days
that's one year and then they'll have
two years and three years so they are
planning for a three period for this
virus and then how it will develop and
how many people will get sick we've
looked at these data on that little
graph that we looked at so we won't have
to go into any of those details so what
would be the impact well the impact will
be major because it will affect not only
Europe it will affect the entire world
so the next question is what measures
will be put in place to curtail the
virus well one of the first one of
course is quarantine yes
and particularly self quarantine now
it's interesting that as we go through
you'll see this is exactly how it was
handled so this is the blueprint and as
far as I can see we are following the
blueprint to a tee at the moment with
one announcement after the other it's
interesting that they say that there
will not be one specific way in which
the various countries will deal with it
there are different blueprints for how
to deal with it and different countries
will use different means and the impacts
will probably vary and this will have
major political repercussions because
some people will play the game the blame
game you know and ask now you know who
did the right thing and who didn't do
the right thing and it's interesting
that politically also with the
disappearances it gets interesting
because some of the critics in China is
I've just disappeared nobody knows where
there are news so it will be isolation
and home isolation and then there will
be other but there will be a reduction
in your basic rights now here's a list
that is fascinating and the right to
your privacy in your home will also be
curtailed in other words even within
your homes fear the arm of the law will
be noticeable and the freedom your basic
human freedom will be curtailed
furthermore by government decree people
can be compelled to be subjected to
inoculation for example or other
measures which they might prescribe okay
so they say that the ramifications in
terms of your your social life will be
astronaut
yes astronomical in other words let's
put it bluntly life will change
completely now not just for a week or a
month but we're talking yes one of the
consequences of course is that vacations
will be canceled or will have to be
postponed this will have drastic effects
on on the tourist industry so the
tourist industry will be terribly
effectiveness now we live in my part of
the world this part of the world
survives 100% almost on the tourist
industry yes so if this really pans out
the way that they are saying then I
think there will be serious
repercussions in the area where we will
live so which areas will be particularly
affected the energy sector for example
electricity gas and and mineral oils etc
should not be affected so that will
continue telecommunication and
information that will continue as far as
air traffic is concerned there will be
massive repercussions
the only flights that will probably
still be allowed would be frightful i'ts
as far as the shipping industry is
concerned freight will continue but of
course wherever people have that will be
curtailed so the tourist industry and
then they go into the various categories
and then they also talk interestingly
about traffic in other words the number
of cars on the road initially that'll
increase dramatically because people
won't be able to take part in public
transport because that's when people
come together yes and because that will
put an extra load on the roads they will
have to be restrictions in terms of the
as well and there will be massive
logistical problems in bringing food
into the area because some borders will
now be activated that might not have
been activated before and I find it
interesting that Poland for example
which is part of the EU yes is now not
able to bring its trucks in and out so
the the borders that were gone on now
their Italy is less or this has been a
comma so all of these various areas are
impacted even though they shouldn't be
there will be of course massive impacts
on on the medical sphere and on
pharmaceuticals also very interesting is
nutrition now the production of food
will continue but it will be majorly
impacted because the people will be sick
the farmers will be sick some of them
will be dying so there will be a massive
reduction including the massive
reduction of food coming into the area
so it seems as though a simplified
lifestyle is on the cards yes and life
as usual with luxury and all of those
things will be a thing of the past it
reminds me of the regulations in the
Second World War
yes or even in the first when there were
such major restrictions on food and for
example certain luxury items like flour
white flour was not allowed it was
permitted it was forbidden by law only
the military was allowed to get some of
these things and you know what's
fascinating in Sweden for example and in
Norway in the Nordic countries all the
meat and all the pork production was
confiscated because it went to the
military in World War II during the
World War II yes when the Nazi regime
was trying to take over the world all of
those food items went to the military
and the people had to revert to a very
simple lifestyle and disease dropped
race yes heart disease cancer the graph
just dropped precipitously and the
people were healthy but in the middle of
raising so that for example Romo had to
add one stage for bed the eating of poke
because his soldiers was eased as a
consequence so on the one hand this is
bad news on the other hand it might not
be such bad news you know what there's a
statement that I have read where it says
that what we eat impacts the mind yes
and if we had a simpler diet we might
have better discernment as to what is
going on so maybe this is a mechanism
even though it is in this pandemic
scenario to get mankind to get a clearer
mind because the issue is much larger
than a virus in my opinion so yes there
will be major impact on the way we
survive and I'm sure that some people
will have serious problems with that so
the banks will continue and the stock
exchange will continue and Parliament
and all of these will continue the
justice system will be impacted I found
it interesting that they said for
example that juries will no longer be
allowed okay because of yeah so one
judge will decide what's right or wrong
the jury is gone because then you have a
collection of people together and that's
a serious issue so there will be massive
problems when it comes to garbage and
refuse removal and they estimate that at
least 7.5 million
people will die of the virus over the
next three years now and that is only in
Germany or zet worldwide this is what
they're saying about Germany but you
know if you if you divide that by the
three years then well people die every
year and is this something that is
extraordinary now there's another thing
that might might happen there could be a
massive increase in burglaries yes as
people become more affected by the
restrictions and looting and looting and
plundering and a lot of illegal selling
of fake medication and against civil
unrest against society when I had this
when I look at the prophetic scenario I
find an interesting quote in the book
education and it says at the same time
anarchy is seeking to sweep away all law
not only divine but human the
centralizing of wealth and power the
vast combination for enriching of the
few at the expense of the many the
combination of the poorer classes for
the defense of their interests and
claims the spirit of unrest of riot and
bloodshed and the worldwide
dissemination of the same teachings that
led to the French Revolution all
attending to involve the whole world in
a struggle similar to that which
convulsed France when I when I think of
Bernie Sanders for example with his
agenda and he's railing against the
disparity between the rich and the poor
although he's not for himself right
correct didn't one of his staffers say I
said guillotine the rich guillotine the
rich this is this is so reminisce
of this statement so french revolution
sort of ideology that led to the French
Revolution are all tending to involve
the whole world is in a struggle similar
to that which convulsed France such are
the influences to be met by the youth of
today to stand amidst this upheaval they
are now to lay the foundation of
character thou shalt love the Lord thy
God with thy whole heart and with our
whole mind and with thy whole soul so if
we look at all of these political
ramifications then it is astounding that
we are following this blueprint to the T
so the airlines will no longer operate
for touristic travel or travel in
general your household will be affected
in it already
Boeing is asking for a trillion dollar
bailout to get to just keep afloat in
fact in the document they say that
governments will probably have to bail
out and other statements on the internet
that governments will have to bail out
these large industries or else they will
not survive and then of course the
psychological effects you will have to
keep away from large groups of people so
we are restricting them to below a
hundred and later maybe to below 50 so
freedom of association will change now
there is also a way besides preventing
the spread of disease to control people
so that you don't have anarchy
developing under these conditions and if
the hand of the law stretches right into
your home now what if it stretches all
the way to your communication isn't
there a law to be passed in Israel now
that
your cell phone will be monitored what
is that all about says the government
okay is a mass surveillance of Israelis
phones to curb coronavirus so there's a
lot of legislation that is being put in
place and surveillance that has been
perfected to a tea in China
yes and that same technology is
available in in the rest most countries
in the world already exactly can be used
in this situation as well so you're not
allowed to have this association and you
have to avoid public life the things
that happen in public life sport will be
influenced all of these and of course
your permission to be in certain places
at certain times so what is that what is
the impact going to be well small
industry will suffer the most already
the cafes are closing any
privately-owned little industry will not
be able to probably survive this and I
find this rather interesting and I don't
think we have to say any more about the
document because it is a blueprint that
is being followed to a tea yes is it
justified is the question that this
doctor asked and his question fascinated
me if this is orchestrated which we are
not saying it is because it's genuine
but if it were who would benefit and
whether it is orchestrated or whether it
is not orchestrated is actually
irrelevant because we are basically in
this situation for whatever reason and
it seems as if the situation is not
going to go away very soon the laws are
becoming more and more stringent and I
have a sneaking feeling
that this is either a preparation or it
is the real thing when it comes to what
we have been waiting for for a very long
time the final events on this planet and
the laws that are associated with it
will become even more fascinating if we
look into some of those but we'll come
to that in a moment if this is real and
if it's going to pan out like the
blueprint says then is it possible that
we have entered the little time of
trouble and is it possible that the
statements which we have had are slowly
coming to fulfillment I have a statement
here from Adventist home which says
again and again it was shown that our
people are to take their families away
from the cities into the country where
they can raise their own provisions for
in the future the problem of buying and
selling will be very serious one we
should now begin to heat the instruction
given us over and over again get out of
the cities into the rural districts
where the houses are not crowded closely
together and where you will be free from
the interference of enemies is there
still time or we perhaps a little bit
late already be that as it may we've had
this instruction for a long long time
and why won't you be able to buy or sell
we spoke about that in a previous
program not because your bank card is no
longer operative the banking system will
continue according to this document but
what if there is nothing on the shelf
yes and isn't that what is happening we
have the stores closing and you have all
the web pages the empty shelves now we
are living in the tiniest little town if
you blink your message news and the
stores are empty even here even here and
this is the southern tip of Africa where
none of these regulations have really
taken effect yet they are just talking
about them and if you think about Europe
the shelves are empty and I think about
a conversation I had with a young person
about a year ago and that person was
vehemently against the idea that we are
living close to the end of time and we
have a little garden it's not a very big
garden but it produces some tomatoes and
some vegetables and letters here and the
letters there and they were questioning
why we would do that
why would bother I mean why not just go
down the road and go to Costco and I
said to that young person this is a year
ago I said to this young person what if
you go to Costco and the store is empty
what if there's nothing on the Shelf
what are you gonna do then and they
looked at me as if I've fallen off a bus
and said are you crazy
it's never been like that and it won't
be like that in the future and I said
well you better pray that it stays that
way and just one year later the shelves
are empty now I'm not being a a fear
monger but if this is a reality then I
believe that we could be very close to
the time that we have been waiting for
and it's not going to be a pleasant time
it's going to be a hard time and as
anarchy increases and as laws are
enacted that enforce the new status quo
then we will see major changes in the
world now already the government's have
announced that they
released the military to take care of
some of these issues certain personnel
will be empowered to enforce these laws
already in France if you are on the
street after a certain time you will be
fine yes and these laws will become more
and more stringent hasn't Donald Trump
released the National Guard is thousand
troops in six states in response to
coronavirus and national states of
emergency have been declared in various
countries already now the next move of
the state of emergency is martial law
yes
now what if martial law is applied
because the interesting thing about
martial law is it overrides the law of
the land if that means that if martial
law is declared then the constitutions
are no longer valid
now there's another point which we need
to discuss which is absolutely
fascinating and that is the Noahide laws
now Noahide laws are cabbalistic laws
they come from the Kabbalah so Kabbalah
is Jewish mysticism and from Jewish
rabbis and according to this philosophy
which you don't find in the Bible by the
way you find it in the Talmud and if you
read the Talmud then you're reading a
fascinating document which might have
elements of the Bible in it but their
own interpretation of course is very
different for example if you read about
Jesus Christ in the Talmud then your
hair will stand on inch no offence not
yours but
but that is that is the scenario now
what on our hide laws according to this
philosophy these laws were given
originally to Adam and Eve and then of
course when that first population
disappeared it was given to the
antediluvian x' or to the to the post
eluvians which would then be known and
so now they called Noahide laws and they
proceeded sinai according to this
philosophy and therefore they are
applicable not to one people like the
Jews for example but applicable to all
humanity and you would think that these
Noahide laws would be you know just part
of the Jewish philosophy no no no
they're supposed to be a very name Noah
Hite says that they are applicable to
all of humanities now those people that
are interested in the New World Order
they say that these laws must be applied
to every nation it must become a
universal law now there are seven
Noahide laws and we don't have to go
into detail about what they say but the
first one says do not profane God's
oneness in any way and that's a very
fascinating law because do not profane
God's oneness in any way so this effects
largely the monotheistic religions and
you know that the Pope had this meeting
about monotheistic religions coming
together to work together and we spoke
about that last time about how the
Abrahamic faiths the Abrahamic faiths
religion etc etc etc now it's
interesting that everybody must adhere
to these Noahide laws do not cursed your
Creator so there's a religious element
in these laws right do not murder do not
eat the limb of a living animal this law
was apparently
added later although Adam and Eve
apparently only received six laws okay
but this one was added after the flight
if yes so you have to respect God's
creatures there's there are
environmental laws if you break this
down further so the environment will be
very important do we have those issues
today do not steal
that's an interesting Lord to me because
in the rerum Novarum the papal
encyclical it says that if you have need
you may
it's called mint you'll need out of the
riches of others which to my knowledge
is called stealing but nevertheless
you're not supposed to steal in this
perfect world which will be the new
society of humanity and then harness and
channel the human libido now that's
interesting because what does that
actually mean
it means that incest adultery rape and
homosexual relations are forbidden now
out of these only to at the moment
austell forbidden which is incest and
rape nobody
there's no law against the doctrine they
used to be laws against adultery but
they're gone and rape is still a problem
homosexuality of course is not a problem
so would these returned with a vengeance
and then seven established courts of law
and ensured justice in our world to the
point of course where if you transgress
the Noahide laws there is the
possibility of the death penalty or
punishment capital punishment correct
now are these just hypothetical laws now
if they were it would be interesting
particularly the first one do not
profane God's oneness in any way now the
Talmud is a document that
some very very negative things to say
about Jesus Christ and one of the things
that the the Talmud and the Jews and the
Bible even had against Jesus is that he
claimed that he and his father were one
yes and they picked up stones to stone
him because you are saying that you are
equal with God right so anybody
basically if you analyze it who says
that Jesus Christ is God my Lord could
come into conflict with the Noahide laws
now are there only hypothetical when the
answer is no they are not because George
Bush Senior
he made that famous speech about a new
world order where all the nations you
know work together and come together and
that this is now a distinct possibility
he actually in acted as law the Noahide
laws in 1991 correct is there a webpage
to that we've get actually you can go to
the Congress cough web page so that's
the official government weather official
government web page and then on that is
the whole section that they've entered
as a law so the no hide laws are already
on the books in the United States of
America now of course they were never
enacted because as they are written they
would be against the Constitution
correct which permits you to worship in
whatever way that you deem according to
your conscience is necessary right yes
what if the Constitution is suspended
under martial law
then the Noahide law would be active yes
that's interesting there are what about
Europe one of the previous presidents of
Europe from rompe yes by the way was
highly acclaimed by the Jesuits as one
of their men
well Lisa
that he seeks greater dissemination of
the universal values known as the
Noahide laws and then also it goes on to
say that Major General Michael Jeffrey
governor-general of Australia lamenting
family breakdowns and drug and alcohol
abuse in modern society in a 2008 later
wrote that he believed that observing
the fundamental values of the Noahide
laws can be an antidote to such ills of
society so the Noahide laws are already
law in the United States yes they're
just not active because of the
Constitution but they are already there
I find that fascinating and by a man who
said that he is for this new world order
now and it's called education day that
law huh
so it's called Education Day and the
Pope wants to bring together a meeting
on education so all of this is beginning
to come together now according to my
Bible the little Horn of Daniel chapter
7 is the papacy that's how Protestants
have seen it throughout their history
and because the criteria phat 100% it
cannot change yes and if he is the
little horn the eb is the antichrist
then he has an agenda which is
determined to dethrone jesus christ from
the throne and in this time of crisis
and it's fascinating to me that this
document that we read said three years
yes because that is the Counter
Reformation theology on the reign of the
Antichrist which will take place between
three and three and a half years right
yes so do we have the table laid for the
final events to take place on this earth
then I think yes I think yes it's a
great possibility it is possible that it
might fizzle out in two or three or four
months and business as usual
then it was a practice run yes or maybe
even a genuine occurrence
we do not know time will tell but if
this is the real thing then we could be
now in the little time of trouble yes
and according to the prophetic scenario
it will escalate and escalate and
escalate until there comes a direct
clash between God's law and man's law
yes and we know that the papal system is
deeply involved in all of this you can
just see it in the preparations done by
Jesuit theater yeah which is called
Hollywood or example and in the
philosophies that are espoused by these
individuals so I would like to say that
God's people should now stand up this is
the time to bring the loud cry message
this is the time not to be silent this
is the time to speak by every possible
means we have to warn the world because
when this comes to its final analysis
and the mark of the beast is implemented
then we will go into the big time of
trouble and the plagues will fall and it
will be too late to reach those that we
want to reach
I believe God in His mercy is permitting
all of us and even ease the final play
in the prophetic outline then he is
permitting it so that people can wake up
and people can either go with the stream
or they can follow the directives of the
Word of God as far as I am concerned and
I think as far as you are concerned the
Word of God is the standard not the
Talmud not any other document not any
Distortion
I want to know what God said
it's very important that I know what God
said and how do I find out today what
God said well it's in his Bible but I
want to know exactly what God said and
perhaps we can talk about that issue in
a subsequent discussion thank you for
listening and may God bless you and may
God give you strength and may we stand
united under the blood-stained banner of
Jesus Christ the man who died for your
and my sin and who is God manifest to
man amen thank you very much for
watching Walter I think it would be
appropriate if you closed off us also
with a word of Prayer please Heavenly
Father you have given us a blueprint in
your word and you have sketched the
developments of this world in advance
and the events that have been spoken
about in Matthew 24 seem to be unfolding
before our very eyes Heavenly Father we
are looking through a glass darkly
we do not know Lord whether this is the
final event before the great
manifestations and the coming of Christ
whether this is a practice run because
we do not know the time all we can look
at is the signs and the signs are
screaming to heaven and if this is it
Lord then I pray that you will wake up
your people that they will come out of
their slumber and that they will reunite
honor thus says the Lord because that
will be our only sure footing and may
you bless them and may you keep them
according to your power in Jesus name
Amen
I mean thank you see you next time
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click yes when the bell
appears click and you will receive
notifications to watch the next one
click yeah thank you again and see you
next time